[Music]
hey Kelly its meteorologist Jennifer
Ketchmark from WCPO 9 in Cincinnati so
after I get done with the newscast each
morning I have other recordings that I
do for whether it's our website or
social media inches of water thanks
Connor mommy's trying to do a little bit
of work and my children do not
understand apparently that mommy needs
five minutes
I got a recourse something real quick
okay but you got to give him some slack
because they're adjusting we're
adjusting but it took everything in me
not to just you know kind of freak out
on my children
water right guys go upstairs my husband
was in the other room on a conference
call so I I definitely couldn't yell as
maybe as loud as I would have liked to I
just I know I nee fine I know it's a
plight that's so many parents across the
country are dealing with as well I mean
this is so unusual and we're all just
trying to make it and get through all of
this go upstairs
three two if anything I learned through
this is that I am definitely not alone
in the struggle to get work done
with the kids at home I'll be upstairs
one minute three two Connor
give mommy a minute please subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going